the road home the new Babylon 5 animated
movie had its World premiere last night
so this feels like a good time to give
you a little bit of an update on what's
going on with the Babylon 5 reboot
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
you look like someone in need of a
friend
so I've talked about Babar five a couple
of times J micro suzinski said he is
working on a reboot a boot up complete
hard reboot of the Babylon 5 series
initially he was asked to do this for
the CW back when a guy called pedowitz
was still in charge a big fan of Babylon
5. before next start came in and bought
the network and basically brought in
reality TV and golf and got rid of
almost everything else so where are we
at now with the Babylon 5 Revival if it
isn't going to be going to the CW which
it doesn't look like it will
well for one let's actually talk about
how we got here so first of all Babylon
5 appeared on HBO Max just uh nearly two
and a half years ago-ish and it did very
well thank you very much off the back of
that it was decided by the CW that they
were going to look into doing a Revival
of Babylon 5 a complete hard reboot they
approached JMS who was more than happy
to write a script which he has done and
they were actually almost almost ready
to go and actually film The Pilot but
then it got delayed initially just for
12 months but this was during the sale
process of the CW and next hour coming
in and now thanks to the right to strike
and the actor strike it's on complete
pause no decision has been made
except for the CW The CW have basically
and not very subtly said that it will
not be appearing on their Network they
released a list basically of shows that
were being canceled or released and
Babylon 5 was not on it with that they
released a statement basically saying
that any TV show we're not renewing will
be released back to the parent company
in this case back to Warner Brothers
so basically HBO Max and Warner Brothers
put Babylon 5 back on the network for a
two-year period to test the waters they
wanted to see what the interest in
Babylon 5 was and that interest was high
so they asked JMS to do the script for
the road home and they used their Warner
Brothers Animation Studios to create
this episode which we're hearing is
great
off the back of that the CW started
thinking well let's get in on this and
let's do a Revival an idea that Warner
Brothers really liked then a CW changed
hands and all of a sudden
Warner Brothers have Babylon 5 all to
themselves now they could put the new
Babylon 5 series on HBO Max but about
six or seven months ago I started
hearing rumors that actually they
weren't going to that they were willing
to sell it to another streaming provider
Netflix Apple apparently very interested
or a couple of others now at the time
this seemed like a very strange
suggestion no one listens to do that for
us because Warner Brothers made stuff
for HBO they didn't really make stuff
for other people but then David zazlab
started to make a few announcements and
basically opened the doors to Warner
Brothers they've started to actually
sell shows to other networks Disney
started doing this as well so stuff that
Warner Brothers produces that
traditionally would have gone straight
on to Max are now appearing on other
networks including Netflix Etc
so all of a sudden Warner Brothers have
made it very clear to the rest of the
world that we're willing to make stuff
and we won't keep it all to ourselves
we're willing to distribute this to
other streaming services the wars are
over we're having an Armistice and let's
all actually start helping each other
Babylon 5 is possibly one of those shows
that is going to go that way as well
that it will actually be sold to
somebody else that's willing to pay for
it and this really is a no-brainer for
Warner Brothers they own one of the
largest studios in the world they own
Warner Brothers animation which is just
like absolutely pounding out great movie
after great movie now they've been doing
it with Batman and Justice League etc
for years they're now doing it with
Babylon 5. I'm here in rumors they're
going to be doing it for other
franchises as well they've got a deal at
the moment with Amazon and they're doing
a Lord of the Rings animated movie
so Warner Brothers are a studio for hire
and it's not just the animation
but actually The Babylon 5 live action
series as well
so yes this is on pause during the
strikes nobody is going to be making any
major decisions writing any scripts or
putting anything in pre-production
JMS has made that very very clear
we are just waiting for the strikes to
end
decisions get made and for Studio that I
believe actually might be apple
to take on the project because all of
this Babylon 5 the original series
appearing on Max for those two years
Babylon 5 the road home animated movie
and now Babylon 5 for the first time
being released on Blu-ray
is not a coincidence there has been a
plan the whole way check that people are
still interested get some excitement and
then hit us with a brand new series
let's be honest a hard reboot of Babylon
5. look we still have the original
Babylon 5 to go watch but
a reimagining by JMS and that's
important remembering the original
Creator is doing this it's not somebody
new it's not somebody that's going to
come and take the piss out of it it's
the original creator
taking all of his experience from
everything he's learned from well when
he did Babylon find the first time
around
but also with modern special effects
modern stages sound stages Etc
this could be
incredibly important
this could actually be genuinely Epic
a hard reboot of Batman 5 the show I
love Yeah to risk
they don't tend to go very well but how
often do they get the original Creator
back
not often
and I cannot wait to see what JMS does
with this I don't actually care where it
ends up
probably won't be the CW but I don't
really care where it ends up I will be
following it I will be subscribing to
whatever that channel is and I will be
binging Babylon 5 the reboot
as soon as I get the opportunity
well guys get into the comments to tell
me what you think I know this is a bit
of a non-up-date update really it's what
I've already told you and obviously
we're waiting for the strikes but it is
important to keep our eye on the Babylon
5 project to keep talking about it and
to make sure we keep the comments going
and the algorithms ticking over
but I want to know what you think about
the Babylon 5 hard reboot is that
something that excites you or would you
rather sort of something that was maybe
an extension to the original series you
know Babylon seven or something I'd love
to know what you think get into the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution you get to see them without
the adverts as always please stay safe
guys and I'll see you soon
all right
[Music]